galina duro va a vivido toda su vida en
este edificio esto es lo que queda ahora
en la noche del domingo rusia volvió a
bombardear intensamente esta zona
residencial en la ciudad oriental de
tourette's dejando varias muertes kalina
temió por su vida
hubo violentas explosiones en todo el
barrio luego todo volvió a la calma y
empecé a cerrar los ojos de repente una
tormenta de humo negro y fuego llenó mi
ventana me levanto del suelo
a pesar de ser el foco de la lucha
terrestre las escenas de destrucción
también son visibles fuera de la región
del tumbas en jarquín la segunda ciudad
del país los disparos de cohetes y
misiles han salpicado la vida cotidiana
desde el inicio de la guerra con los
ataques el lunes por la mañana esta
residente está siendo tratada de
urgencia fuera de su casa tras sufrir
una herida en la cabeza también se han
reportado bombardeos rusos en la ciudad
sureña en mykolaiv y en nikópol donde el
puerto un hospital y dos fábricas
resultaron dañados
los ministros de asuntos exteriores
europeos se plantean ahora endurecer las
sanciones contra el kremlin sanciones
que esperan obliga en algún día a
vladimir putin a poner fin a la guerra
en ucrania